كنا نمرق مثلا نلاقي الكباريه يرحبوا فينا
كله استشهدت الله يرحمها في سوران يعني
صرنا نمرق من الشارع خجولين نحن خجولين ما
بقى نشوف هدول الاشخاص
[موسيقى]
نحن نشتغل بالسحور منفريق العالم مع
السحور عملنا من الساعه ثلاثه وربع حتى
الساعه الرابعه وربع فجرا نحن فريق ست
اشخاص موزعين في صوران بالحارات وبوسطان
هديك السنه نحن اشتغلنا كان في بهجه عنا
في صوران كتير منيحه واستقبال يعني للعالم
لانه بصدر رحب كتير يعني مبسوطين
يعني نطلع ندور بالحارات تطلع العالم على
السحور
والضيفونا تمر كاسه مي مبسوطين الله
يعطيكم العافيه
[موسيقى]
يعني نحن من جواتنا يعني زعلانين
وعنا خيو منكوبين كتير بسبب انه كنا شخص
بنتذكر انه هذا البيت يطلع منه مثلا شخص
يضيفنا حبه تمر كذا اليوم ما بقى نشوفه
لهذا الشخص
[موسيقى]
والله صار في معنا اكتئاب الكل الكل هون
في مدينه صوران صار معنا اكتئاب جميعا
يعني والعالم لحد الان ما هي طبيعيه بعد
الزلزال صلوا تقريبا شي شهر شهر عشره ايام
انا بتمنى العالم كله ساعد بعضها وتساعدو
هالعالم اللي تهدمت بيوته والله يرحم
الشهداء اللي ماتت بسبب الزلزال
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]